i got to go out and play well and if i
don't then people are going to be mad
i'm going to be mad everybody's gonna be
mad so uh my my um focus is to play well
you'll be pressure pressure
no i don't feel pressure
[Music]
you know even looks little standing
behind that podium could they have
gotten a box for him or something i mean
i i hope he's great but he is so little
i love standing next to him it makes me
feel tough
oh yeah big tough mike florio
i i would like to see that fight i don't
think you'd last very oh no no no it
would not last like i would fare about
as well as the other guy
on the on the on the wrong side of the
bag when khalil mack blew him up but but
at least you know it's better to stand
next to a guy who's my height than one
of these when you're doing this you know
holding the microphone up like that so i
always like being around russell wilson
drew brees kyle murray and i hope kyla
murray is great uh and he's been great
every step of the way he feels no
pressure so he's not going to be
included in this edition of pressure
cooker big cat and i are going to go
back and forth with some names i'll let
you go first who's under the most
pressure heading into the season in your
mind okay i'll start with uh a hall of
famer a legend we saw his team last
night it's john elway john elway is
under the pressure cooker because he
cannot figure out the quarterback
position for the denver broncos besides
that year with peyton manning when they
are two years and they go to a super
bowl and then win a super bowl
i don't think
you know he has any idea what's going on
john elway bringing sorry bringing joe
flacco
that's that move makes no sense drew
lock who knows what he's going to be
john elway is under a pressure cooker
because here's the thing the broncos
when you talk about the league's best
teams and best franchises the broncos
are kind of under the radar one of the
best
franchises in all of the nfl and i mean
that by the year in and year out they're
consistently good you've never seen the
broncos go a long stretch where they
have been bad and missed the playoffs
and now if the if the broncos missed the
playoffs again this year maybe win five
games four games
we'll be in that stretch we'll be in
that stretch post super bowl 50 and john
elliott will start having to answer a
lot of tough questions about what the
future of the broncos look like
yeah they didn't have back-to-back
losing seasons since 1971 1972 until
last year and
then they're looking at three in a row
which would not be good for elway the
only thing that's saving him is this
this kind of intra family willy wonka
competition as to who's going to take
over and no one's stepped up yet and
there's a group of trustees that will
figure out who will take over ownership
of the team who will be in charge and i
think while it's still in this kind of
vague ambiguous gulf
it's it's harder to run john elway off
uh so i don't know that he has to worry
about being fired in the short term what
he has to worry about is whether or not
when there is an owner named by these
trustees that that owner is going to
want to stick with elway or want to move
in a new direction so i i agree with you
regardless of whether he has the job or
not he's under a ton of pressure to
prove that he can find a quarterback
other than peyton manning falling into
his lap all right uh mine and this is
obvious and it's so obvious almost
didn't want to pick him but if i don't
pick him people are gonna be like why
the hell didn't you pick the obvious one
the obvious one to me is jason garrett
the head coach of the dallas cowboys
he's in the final year of his contract
he's not getting an extension jerry
jones has basically made it clear the
guy's coaching for his job this year
without coming out and saying it the
circumstances scream it and of anyone in
that organization that should be anxious
and urgent about ezekiel elliott getting
back it would be garrett because garrett
needs elliot to prop up the team so he
can secure his next contract and the
cowboys seem to think he does a better
job when he's feeling that pressure when
he's feeling that he's going to be
feeling it this year
mike they're all coaching for their job
their job is to coach come on now uh all
right my next one mike tomlin mike
tomlin signs an extension you think you
know the pittsburgh steelers never fire
coaches talk about it all the time
they've had what four coaches in the
last 40 years or whatever it may be
i still think that this is a huge year
for mike tomlin because ben
roethlisberger is not going to be the
quarterback forever you had everything
happen with le'veon bell last year you
had everything happen with antonio brown
last year
everyone is sitting there saying okay
you've eliminated these two guys that
might be problems in the locker room my
feeling of the whole situation is the
problems go deeper than that and it's on
mike tomlin because there is something
weird that goes on with the steelers and
it feels like the accountability is kind
of all out of whack
and mike tomlin is going to have a
pressure cooker of a season they have a
ton of talent their defense should be
good and will he be able to step up and
get the steelers back to the playoffs
and beat the patriots because that's
really what it comes down to at this
point for the steelers it feels like
every season can they beat the patriots
and you know some years they beat him in
the regular season they fail in the
playoffs they need to get deep into the
playoffs for mike tomlin to stick around
i've i believe that the extension that
was announced last week it's a one-year
extension with a team option for the
next year beyond that
i think that was done just to get people
like us to quit talking about mike thoma
being on the hot seat they don't want
that hovering over the season it's kind
of like what happens when when when
there's a coaches in the last year of
his contract oh we got to give a new
contract he can't be a lame duck tomlin
was kind of having that lame duck feel
they needed validation from ownership
that he's our guy so we'll quit talking
about tomlin being on the hot seat but
this is a team that is immensely
talented it's underachieved why is it
underachieved well who's responsible for
getting the most achievement possible
out of a talented group of players it's
the head coach and it's going to land on
him if this team ends up being six and
ten seven and nine even eight and eight
if they watch the cleveland browns run
roughshod over that division followed by
the baltimore ravens in second place and
the steelers in third place there's
going to be a tough discussion and it
was reported by ed bouchette of the
athletic that members of the limited
partnership minority owners of the
steelers did not want to give tomlin
that extension we reported back in early
2018 minority owners of the steelers
wanted him fired after the 2017 season
there is a clamoring there when things
don't get well for change and this
extension is not going to keep that from
happening if the steelers fall flat on
their faces this year so i agree with
you on that one so that was a great pick
by me and i just by you i just want the
steelers to know that i know what they
did when they gave mike tomlin an
extension and i'm still going to talk
about him on the hot seat so didn't work
didn't work well uh derek carr got a big
contract from the raiders a couple of
years ago for a small piece of time
maybe six weeks he was the highest paid
player in nfl history until he was
eclipsed by matthew stafford he's got a
25 million a year contract this is the
last year of the guaranteed money after
2019 he is on a year to year arrangement
as the quarterback of the raiders oh and
by the way john gruden earlier this week
gratuitously interjects how much he
loves nathan peterman while answering a
press conference question that wasn't
even about nathan peterman i think derek
carr is on the hot seat in oakland i
think there's a chance he's not going to
be the quarterback when they go to las
vegas and people are making a big deal
out of the fact that derek carr is
building a house next door to john
gruden in las vegas
when does that mean a damn bit of
anything if they don't want him he's not
going to be the quarterback regardless
of where he's building the house this is
upper out for derrick carr mike mayok
said back before the draft the reason
they looked at kyler murray and dwayne
haskins was because they have to always
look for upgrades at every position
including quarterback that is the duty
to the team it's in the best interest of
the franchise to be looking for better
players they're going to find a better
player potentially than derek carr and
they're going to take him because i
don't think carr is a guy that's ever
going to mesh fully and completely with
john gruden and i think this is the year
that that gets proven completely to the
point where the raiders decide to move
on i actually
i think there's a bad pick because i
already just assumed derek carr's out
is that crazy of me
like i don't think it's gonna work is
this like the hot the hot sun is
actually cold theory is that you know
it's so clear that he's gonna be out
that he's not under pressure
uh yeah i think it's not an if it's just
a when so it's almost like he can play
without any pressure knowing that he's
probably out no no no he he believes
that he's he's the guy maybe he feels no
pressure because he's delusional he said
earlier this year he's going to be the
quarterback of the raiders as long as he
wants to be which shows he has no
understanding of how the nfl actually
works so i think this is different i
really do think this is it for him who
else do you have all right i got one a
little a little off the board here mike
i want to hear your thoughts on this i
have jimmy garoppolo jimmy garoppolo
under the pressure cooker because jimmy
garoppolo has been anointed as a
franchise quarterback he got paid a ton
of money and then he gets hurt which
obviously not his fault but we don't
know what jimmy garoppolo is we have not
seen jimmy garoppolo play a full regular
season of football in the nfl so
pressure cooker because kyle shanahan is
a fantastic coach one of i think the
best offensive minds we have in the nfl
right now if jimmy garoppolo can't do it
with him right away especially
considering the fact that he hasn't
proven it like year in and year out i
think jimmy garoppolo is low key
under the pressure cooker to perform and
perform fast to prove to the 49ers and
the fan base that he is worth every
dollar that they paid him
you know how you sometimes get annoyed
with me when you realize that i don't
listen to every episode of the pardon my
take podcast are you familiar with that
concept yes yes
you apparently pay no attention to
anything that i write about at
profootballtalk.com i've been banging
this drum for weeks that this is it for
jimmy garoppolo that next year you know
what the cap charge would be if they cut
jimmy garoppolo after this season 4.2
million dollars that is peanuts given
what that they have
invested into jimmy garoppolo they can
move on from him quickly they can move
on from him easily and the other side of
this jimmy garoppolo hot take which has
gotten a lot of 49ers fans pissed off at
me i firmly believe that if kirk cousins
doesn't have a great year with the
minnesota vikings there could be a trade
in the offing where kyle shanahan
finally gets the guy that he wanted the
guy he thought he was going to get
before they traded for jimmy garoppolo i
could see garoppolo out after this year
and cousins in next year as the
quarterback of the 49ers but to answer
your question no i don't read or consume
any mike florio content except for when
i'm on this show
all right well hey today we're on the
same page as it relates to jimmy
garoppolo i got one more real quick dave
gettleman the giants gm now i don't know
that he would be fired the giants don't
fire gm's just like the steelers don't
fire coaches and i think one of the
reasons they don't fire gm's i think
john mara essentially runs the team and
uses the gm as the buffer so he doesn't
look like he's meddling but gentleman's
really out on the limb here with the
odell beckham jr trade and how they're
handling daniel jones the sixth overall
pick in the draft and eli manning's
still the quarterback and do they have
enough talent and if this team is just a
disaster this year it's all going to
fall on gettlemen and uh regardless of
whether he he may be at the part where
he doesn't want to continue to be the gm
of the giants because of all the
criticism and all the scrutiny that he
has to endure i think he's under a ton
of pressure hot seat or not pressure
galore for dave gettleman one last one
your guy mike zimmer
another little p1
low key one i i don't listen i think
mike zimmer's a fantastic coach but when
the vikings were knocking on the door a
couple years ago
and you know you can say the teddy
bridgewater thing set them back you can
obviously say kirk cousins play last
year i think it's one of those
situations it kind of reminds me of like
a lovey smith where it's maybe not the
the coaches uh
fault that they're underperforming and
maybe they even win eight nine ten games
it's just the fact that guys might not
be you know listening the way they they
should be and the message starts to get
a little muddled there and a year after
year after year
there was no disastrous year but it
feels like there should just be a change
for change sakes which i'm not saying is
a great idea i think the bears kind of
set themselves back when they fired
lovey smith and went into the tressman
woods and the john fox woods but it had
it happens in the nfl and i think mike
zimmer is right around that time if the
vikings underperformed this year
i i i personally think that the wolfs
are all in with zimmer and that they are
not inclined to have a a revolving door
they've been very good about now that
they've they've got a coach that they
like they're sticking with rick
spielman's been the gm of that team for
over a decade now they like stability
and i think they're going to stick with
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports